sans surprise les sénateurs ont confirmé
ce lundi soir à washington la nomination
de cette mère de sept enfants âgée de 48
ans au poste de juge de la cour suprême
au fauteuil laissé vacant par ruth bader
ginsburg décédé en septembre dernier une
simple formalité si on regarde la
majorité républicaine au sénat 53 sièges
contre sens dans l'enceinte
mais il faut dire que le sujet a créé
beaucoup de débats et de dissension il
faut dire que l'enjeu est de taille
selon les propres mots de donald trump
est lui même nommé un juge à la cour
suprême est la plus importante décision
que peut prendre un président des états
unis rien que cela
donald trump en tout cas aura bien
profité de cette situation puisqu'il
aura renouvelé un tiers de la cours avec
six juges sur neuf alors pourquoi est-ce
aussi important et bien parce que cette
nouvelle juge aura en charge avec ses
comparses évidemment de se prononcer sur
des sujets aussi majeure que
l'avortement le mariage homosexuel ou le
sujet épineux de l'assurance-santé
l'obamacare qui sera d'ailleurs débattu
à la cour suprême à partir du 10
novembre
d'où la colère et la grande inquiétude
des démocrates qui crient au vol et
craignent justement le démantèlement de
l'obamacare on écoute
elizabeth warren ya 37 jours mitch
mcconnell a déclaré qu'il ignorait le
souhait le plus fervent de ruth bader
ginsburg et engagerait la procédure
fossé et légitimes visant à la remplacer
à la cour suprême
huit jours à peine huit jours avant
l'élection
alors que des dizaines de millions
d'américains ont déjà voté et seulement
15 jours avant que la cour suprême
étudie un casse qui pourraient abroger
la ford et bolquère actes donald trump
mitch mcconnell et leurs comparses du
parti républicain bafoue la volonté du
peuple américain afin d'usurper ce siège
à la cour suprême au il n'y a pas que
l'obamacare qui pose problème le sujet
qui est sur toutes les lèvres en ce
moment c'est évidemment les
hexion présidentielle et pour cause 60
millions d'américains ont déjà voté par
correspondance en raison certainement de
la pandémie donald trump met
régulièrement en garde contre des
élections truquées en cas d'invalidité
le président américain a déjà prévenu
qu'il souhaiterait que la cour suprême
jouent un rôle important
arbitre en quelque sorte est les litiges
et que justement la juge
barrett soit en première ligne sur ce
sujet le chef de file des républicains
au sénat lui préfère être rassurant et
mettre en avant les compétences de la
nouvelle juge pour nous assurer le
maintien de la séparation des pouvoirs
garantir les droits des citoyens il nous
faut pour voir nos tribunaux avec des
personnes de très grande qualité
c'est une grande chance pour notre pays
que le sénat viennent de confirmer l'une
des candidates les plus qualifiés de
cette génération pour le service
judiciaire la juge amy koné barrettes de
la cour d'appel américaine du 7e ressort
est une candidate exceptionnelle sous
tous les aspects mais c'est tout aussi
important
madame barrette a fait preuve de son
refus absolu d'imposer ses opinions
personnelles ou de bricoler de nouvelles
politiques à coups de décision de
justice elle a manifesté l'humilité
devant la loi la neutralité et la
loyauté à notre constitution qui sont
essentiels pour ce poste une cérémonie
en l'honneur de la nouvelle juge à mi
koné barrette devait se tenir dès ce
lundi soir à la maison blanche
faux